Eric Weinstein and and of course you
know Peter white and and many others
that have alternative theories
alternatives to string theory and you
did your thesis I believe in 1986 on
string theory which is you know kind of
the salad days and I want to ask you if
you had to appraise AR priz String
Theory I asked Mike Turner about
inflation and dark energy recently gave
him the same thing give strength Theory
a grade A report card and break it down
into the sub categories of strength
where is it conceeded where does it need
more work and where is the parent
teacher conference going to happen the
only reason I'm laughing is because the
25th and this is not a plug folks so it
doesn't matter but it's just because you
ask the question the 25th anniversary
edition of the elegant universe is
coming out in August and on the final
pages of this new chapter I've written I
give String Theory a report card so part
of me is like hey I don't really want to
spill the beans right here but but I'll
give you a rough feel for it so it's a
good way of phrasing it because you need
to judge a theory among uh many
different Criterion right and and some
strength has done extremely well and
some it hasn't done as well so let me
start with this stuff where it hasn't
done as well when it comes to making
contact with
experimental data the very question that
we began with strength here is not as
far along as I would have hoped right so
back in 1986 I don't want to calculate
how many years ago that was it was a
long time ago and if you would have
asked me then and I think most string
theor at the time 2023
are we going to know through experiment
or observation whether these ideas are
correct 95% of the community said of
course we'll know by then and yet here
we are and and we don't know so on that
I would give a relatively low grade but
I'm going to come back to how I'll give
the final grade on that in just a second
because the theoretical developments in
strength Theory have been so
astonishingly powerful well beyond
anything that I would have anticipated
back in
1986 and one development in particular
that no doubt you know something about
because it's the most famous development
in the last 20 years this ads CFT
correspondence by Juan Mala and actually
again it's a whole great it's a whole
community of people of course but Juan
wrote the paper that really took the
World by storm the relevance of that
well it's got a huge degree of relevance
but the relevance to the experimental
question is interesting because once we
learned as we did with Juan's Insight
that string theory is not as a radical
separation from previous methodology as
we once thought which is a great
development there's a deep connection to
older techniques that are still at the
Forefront because they're our most
powerful techniques Quantum field Theory
once you learn that Quantum field Theory
and string theory are joined at the hip
which is what onean showed us Quantum
field theory is the
most powerfully tested theory in the
history of of particle physics in the
history of quantum mechanics it's a
framework that works tested in what
sense tested in terms of internal
consistency philosophical expediency in
what way has it been I'm talking
flat-footed here take the standard model
of particle physics it's a PE Quantum
field Theory and that particular Quantum
field Theory makes predictions that we
can confirm I mean uh you know take the
Magnetic Moment of the electron right
yeah that's is that not the most insane
it's the most accurately known number
yeah so so so think about the fact that
you can do a calculation using this
framework of quum and field Theory it
agrees to Observation to that many
decimal places right so so that's the
sense in which these ideas have been
rigorously tested when you learn that
that
framework is intimately connected to the
framework of string theory that they're
not these two radically different things
which is what we initially thought it
doesn't prove string theory of course
but it shows you that we are within the
same universe of ideas all of a sudden
and that to me mitigates to some extent
that string theory has not gone as far
as we had hope to actually make an
experimental prediction that we can
confirm but the fact that it has joined
together with the most experimentally
tested approach that is good that's
strong did I leave somebody out of the
discuss your friend you guys have
debated and had a memorable exchange at
the Ia conference where he said
something and you said well maybe we
were over exuberant he said like the
Meli
Massacre as only Eric Weinstein could do
Brian Green like I had this interchange
with Brian Green where I said we're not
being honest about the failure of string
theory and Brian's like oh well maybe we
were a little bit exuberant and I I
blurred out Institute for arts and ideas
I blurred
out that's like saying
mili my mili was irrational exuberance
no you put a lot of people's careers in
the in the shredder so his geometric
Unity Theory which features some
testable predictions and again I'm an
experimentalist right so I'm looking for
well what things could we do say how
would the prediction of Garrett's Theory
or Steven's Theory or Ava Silverstein
you know any idea how will that affect
observables that say the Simon's
Observatory can measure one of the
things we can do is measure abundances
we can measure look for spin depend
phenomena and those theories and I think
the thing that Eric always harps on is
that we don't we seem I say we
collectively as physicist and I'm
including myself uh even though I'm not
a theorist but um in in the things that
seem to not trouble us troubles Eric in
other words why is it that we have three
families of Fons and we don't have an
explanation for that we just we just
sort of know it as a taxonomy and as
binan said just because you know the
name of something tells you bubus about
it right does that trouble you I mean is
that part of hey if you go back
Yeah you mentioned my thesis which I
haven't thought about in a very long
time but um you know the point of that
thesis was to try to answer why there
are three generations from a string
theoretic perspective and way back then
there were only a handful of known
shapes for the extra Dimensions that
string theory requires and in string
theory the number of generations of
particles is related to a geometrical
quantity in the extra dimensions half
the oiler characteristic for those who
are keeping score at home and so if you
have three generations you're looking
for Oiler characteristic six okay and
there were only really three known
examples that had been constructed
around those times and with a colleague
another graduate student at Ox we proved
that two of them were actually the same
ah so unified so we unified them so
we're sort of down you know by one and
uh I may be a grand ising but I think we
also in the third one so I think we
basically got it down to one if I'm if
I'm maybe being generous with myself 40
years later but it was it was one or two
I believe it was one and so what we did
was we then went further and tried to
calculate the mass of the electron or
the mass of the other particles from
this particular geometrical form the
extra dimensions and at that time with
the limited mathematical understanding
which has since become much more deep we
got partway down that road but as we did
more and more shapes for the extra
Dimensions were discovered so all of a
sudden this motivation to study one well
if there're only four or five total and
only one with three generations of
course you're going to study it but then
when they're 500 or 10,000 or 10 to the
500 your motivation for studying any
specific example drops precipitously so
that is the historical way but yes does
it does it intrigue me this question of
why there are three generations
absolutely